Put summer's fresh strawberries to good use by turning them into a delicious pie.
Step 1: Wash the strawberries and remove their tops.
Slice them lengthwise into pieces and place half of them into the pastry shell,...
...setting the rest aside.
To avoid a runny pie, do not soak the strawberries in water.
Step 2: Mash the remaining strawberries and combine them with the sugar.
Bring the mixture to a boil over medium heat, stirring frequently.
Step 3: Whisk together the cornstarch and water...
...and then gradually stir this mixture into the boiling strawberry mixture.
Step 4: Reduce the heat and simmer and stir constantly until the mixture thickens,...
...about ten minutes.
Add two tablespoons of white corn syrup to the pan to achieve a thicker sugary glaze.
Step 5: Let the filling cool and then pour it into the pastry shell.
Step 6: Chill the pie in your freezer before serving.
Add a dollop of whipped cream for an ultimate delight.
Did you know?
The commonly cultivated strawberry originated in Europe in the 18th century.